I SAY RIGHT NOW WE TURN
TOWARDS THE MIDDLE EAST.
>> YEMEN EVOLVES INTO CHAOS.
SAUDI TANKS ON THEIR WAY TO THE
BORDER.
>> IRAN DEPLOYING ITS WARSHIPS
TO THE GULF OF ADEN.
>> A MUCH LARGER PROXY WAR
BETWEEN SHIITES AND SUNNIS.
>> YEMEN HAS LONG BEEN HOME
TO AL QAEDA.
>> THE HOUTHI REBELS HAVE TAKEN
OVER SANAA.
>> THE U.S. ALSO STEPPING UP
AIR STRIKES ON ISIS.
>> IT'S GETTING VERY, VERY
COMPLICATED.
>> Jon: WELL, TO BE FAIR, HE
IS EASILY CONFUSED.
BUT IN THIS CASE, IT'S TRUE.
THERE'S SO MANY PROXY WARS
GOING ON IN THE MIDDLE EAST,
IT ALMOST APPEARS AT TIMES THAT
WE ARE FIGHTING OURSELVES.
TO HELP US UNDERSTAND TO THE
VARIOUS ANGLES OF OPERATION
SANDY QUAGMIRE WE ARE
JOINED BY SENIOR MIDDLE EAST
CORRESPONDENT BASSEM YOUSSEF.
BASSEM, THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE, MY FRIEND.
GREAT TO SEE YOU. GREAT TO SEE
YOU, BASSEM.
>> YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
>> Jon: NICE TO SEE YOU.
>> THANK YOU, THANK YOU. YEAH,
YEAH, YEAH.
WHATEVER, JON, WHATEVER.
YEAH. YEAH. YEAH. YEAH.
>> Jon: I GOT TO TELL, YOU
SEEM LESS THAN EXCITED TO BE
HERE.
LAST TIME IT SEEMED LIKE YOU
WERE EXCITED TO BE HERE.
WHAT IS UP, BASSEM. TALK TO ME.
>> YEAH, NOTHING.
ALTHOUGH I SEE THAT WHILE I
WAS AWAY, YOU PICKED SOME
OTHER GUY TO REPLACE YOU.
>> Jon: TREVOR NOAH, THAT'S
RIGHT.
HE'S GOING TO REPLACE ME ON
THE PROGRAM WHEN I LEAVE.
THAT'S, THAT'S --
>> SO YOU WANTED A HANDSOME
YOUNG COMEDIAN FROM AFRICA?
HELLO!
YEAH, YEAH!
WHAT, JON, EGYPT IS NOT
AFRICAN ENOUGH FOR YOU?
>> Jon: OH YEAH, EGYPT IS IN
AFRICA.
>> YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
SO JON, YOU CAN IMAGINE WHAT
A BEAUTIFUL ROLLING STONE COVER
I WOULD HAVE HAD--
(LAUGHTER)
>> Jon: WHO IS HOLDING YOUR
CHEST THERE?
>> THERE WAS SOMEONE HOLDING
MY CHEST?
>> Jon: YES, I THINK SO.
>> WELL, ANYWAY, YOU HAD SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE MIDDLE
EAST.
>> Jon: YES.
>> YEAH SO, AS WE SAY WHERE
I COME FROM, SHOOT.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Jon: ALL RIGHT.
SO HERE IS THE DEAL, HERE IS
WHAT I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
WE'RE FIGHTING ISIS AND AL
QAEDA.
WE'RE TRYING TO KEEP NUKES AWAY
FROM IRAN BUT NOW WE'RE
SOMEHOW INVOLVED IN A PROXY
WAR IN YEMEN ON THE SIDE OF
IRAN BUT NOT-- HERE IS MY
QUESTION, WHO SHOULD WE
WORRY ABOUT?
WHO IS ACTUALLY COMING TO
KILL US?
>> NONE OF THEM.
>> Jon: GET THE [BLEEP] WHAT?
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: SAY THAT AGAIN.
>> WAIT, WAIT, WAIT. LET ME
EXPLAIN.
OKAY, I WILL START WITH MY
COUNTRY, EGYPT.
>> Jon: YOU KNOW IT IS IN
AFRICA.
>> VERY GOOD, JON, YOU'RE
LEARNING. OKAY, SO REMEMBER THE
MUSLIM BROTHERHOOD.
>> Jon: YES, YES, GUNS,
BEARDS, SUNNI, BRIEFLY IN
CHARGE OF EGYPT.
>> YES, UNTIL THE MILITARY
THREW THEM OUT WITH BACKING
FROM THE SAUDIS.
WELL NOW, THE SAUDIS AND THE
EGYPTIAN ARMY ARE FIGHTING
SHIITE REBELS TOGETHER IN
YEMEN.
AND GUESS WHO IS FIGHTING
ALONGSIDE THEM.
>> Jon: YES, YES, IT'S CHUCK
NORRIS.
>> YES, CLOSE, THE MUSLIM
BROTHERHOOD IN YEMEN.
>> Jon: THE MUSLIM
BROTHERHOOD IN YEMEN ARE
ALLIES WITH THE GUYS WHO
THREW THEM OUT OF EGYPT.
THEY'RE BUDDIES NOW.
>> OF COURSE NOT, THEY JUST
LIKE HATE THE [BLEEP]
OUT OF EACH OTHER.
>> Jon: ALL RIGHT.
>> THEY JUST HAPPEN TO BE
POINTING THEIR GUNS AT THE
SAME PEOPLE RIGHT NOW.
AND GUESS WHO ELSE IS
ROOTING FOR TEAM SAUDI?
>> Jon: CHUCK NORRIS' BROTHER?
>> CLOSE.
ISIS AND AL QAEDA.
THOSE ASSHOLES ARE SO HAPPY
THAT SHIA ARE GETTING
KILLED IN YEMEN, THEY ARE
POPPING THEIR HALAL CHAMPAGNE.
>> Jon: BUT THAT, SO THAT'S WHAT
THIS IS THOUGH.
SO THE WAY TO FIGURE THIS OUT
IS THE SUNNI SHIA SPLIT,
SUNNI'S ALWAYS GONNA HAVE A
SUNNI'S BROTHER'S BACK.
>> YES.
>> Jon: YES.
>> EXCEPT IN IRAQ.
>> Jon: GOD.
>> WHERE THE SUNNI COALITION
IS FIGHTING ALONGSIDE THE SHI'A
MILITIAS AGAINST ISIS.
>> Jon: THIS IS NUTS -- IS THIS
SOME KIND OF NEW PSYCHOLOGICAL
TERRORISM WHERE THEY TRY TO
CONFUSE US TO DEATH?
>> LET ME PUT THIS IN TERMS
YOU CAN UNDERSTAND.
YOU KNOW MARCH MADNESS?
>> Jon: OF COURSE I KNOW MARCH
MADNESS.
>> GOOD. CONSIDER THIS CONSTANT
INTRACTABLE MADNESS.
LOOK HOW MANY TEAMS HAVE TO
PLAY AGAINST EACH OTHER AND
THIS IS JUST ONE DIVISION.
WE'RE NOT EVEN TO THE ELITE
EIGHT YET.
AND AMERICA IS ALREADY IN
THE FINALS.
>> Jon: WE'RE IN THE FINALS?
>> YES.
>> Jon: USA!
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT --
>> USA, USA.
>> Jon: WOW, REALLY.
>> THEY'RE SO LIKE
WARMONGERS?
>> Jon: TALKING ABOUT GETTING US
IN A WAR.
>> SERIOUSLY!
>> IS IT REALLY THAT EASY?
ALL RIGHT.
SO WHOEVER MAKES IT OUT OF
THE ROUND OF 64, SUNNI,
SHI'A, MONARCHY, DEMOCRACY,
INSURGENCY, TRIBAL, MILITARY,
THEOCRACY, WHATEVER TEAM,
ADVANCES TO THE FINAL ROUND.
>> GETS TO GO HEAD-TO-HEAD
WITH THE GREAT SATAN.
THAT'S YOU.
>> Jon: WE KNOW.
>> YES.
>> Jon: SO WHO IS YOUR MONEY
ON TO WIN THE WHOLE THING?
>> THE SAME PEOPLE WHO
ALWAYS WIN, THE GUYS WHO RUN
THE GAME.
>> Jon: NCAA. THE NCAA.
>> NO, THE MCAM, MILITARY
CONTRACTORS AND ARMS
MANUFACTURERS.
>> Jon: YEAH, I SEE.
>> YEAH. THEY MAKE MONEY OFF
EVERY TEAM IN THE BRACKET,
AS LONG AS THERE IS MADNESS AND
MARCHING, THEY WIN.